così si muova challenge slime tre colori
non dico lama di colori ad olio
allora in pratica stavo pensando posso
portare un pezzo di pane così facciamo
al boschetto
se vi ricordate un po sul video in cui
prova dipingere per la prima volta
proprio a fare un quadro di bonn rossi
se non lo avete visto note vedendolo con
questo video lo stupore divertente così
mi dite anche se secondo voi ho dipinto
bene o male ben comprato questi colori
ad olio già da un po di tempo però non
li stavo lì utilizzando anche perché si
vuole un po di tempo per dipingere
pensato che non facciamola la slide tre
colori di colla però con il colore ad
olio
ma perché noi invece non fai un dipinto
di merda tutto track quadro è questo
faccia con e magari con sé da allora non
ho mai puntato i colori ad olio per fare
lo slime per colorarlo uno zaino non ho
idea di cosa succeda se questa volta non
mi venisse un po grossi e se non si
l'olio però potrebbe anche solo noi
il bari si separa l'olio dal colore
della promessa se vogliamo che voi
provate fateci sapere nei commenti
comunque lo scopriremo assieme
oggi i tassi sapere nei commenti con
conta altro potremmo fare la spalla di
tre con noi ci sono quattro colori di
verde 4
potresti oggi e non vedo l'ora di vedere
come diventerà noi abbiamo una colla
trasparente non si vedranno benissimo ai
colori eh si non vedo l'ora di vedere
come vivente marche colori spero che
riescano io esperti riescono questo rose
che un viola un vino e poi ci sono un
sacco di colori scuri perché preoccupato
per disegnare più che altro per
disegnare per dipingere gli alberi la
natura quindi mi piacerebbe rose ma
anche il giallo
no aspetta da stare attenta non blu e
giallo e arancione ma termina arancione
quest'altra arancione questo giallo così
bello time arancione che mi ricorda che
questo non era un giallo che non ero
bello che calare vorrebbe che ti si
ribalta e brian blu oppure oppure oppure
il mio letto è molto bello vedremo così
s.mar blu e rosso diventa league in una
nota di merito invece marrone e grigio
ci siamo sposati nel canale digitale
[Musica]
andate a vedere suvvia abbiamo fatto un
disastro nuovamente ma dobbiamo vederlo
consigliati nei commenti che altre salse
tre colori volete che facciamo sempre di
pop corn video tutto schermo in it
smettila chi sicario carta forbice con i
concerti la band ha detto diventi
trasformati in ville e aspetta gli oscar
di notte di torino bene sono tantissimi
ho sentito il rumore del vento e per le
cuffie e che l'umore al grigio e gli
altri come fanno bene del colore da un
errore non sapevo che i colori facessero
dei rumori colori fai il verde verde e
il giallo
questo perché amicale di vitale stiamo
invitando i resti dei pokémon e quindi
ora mi piace in italia quali sony
ok non si deve divertire ma senza bene
sei punti
ma che nello scegliere una o no non ci
credo
guidati per il set si fa ma hanno
buttato così il caso non volevi hai
preso per primo che bello non stavano
già viste le merde 29 di non era ancora
chiuso dall'altro la maledizione del
grigio e del marrone no non ci credo
come è possibile veramente impossibile
ora sai cosa provo io ogni volta che
pesco il verde e come che ti chiama si
richiama e come siamo mica di dire che
io non è un giallo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
viola viola vita media servizi ma viola
però è che non so che cosa è vedere per
avere un brutto né ma volevo io
[Musica]
ecco qua il mio colore tipo marroncino
allora bisogna stare attenti perché
questi colori sono micidiali quindi
bisogna metter me poco cattivo cinema
per non farlo diventare marrone ma
davvero tantissimo
vediamo che neanche si vede questa
cattiva finisco aleggiante abbiamo un po
che strano ma un effetto è stranissimo
profilo l'effetto colore cioè non lo
colora tutto però lo separa tipo
lasciare che colore stanno sembra nero è
nero che cosa c è però potrebbe sembrare
un galaxy visto che fa tutte le stelline
evento anche vero però sembra un po
anche scoperto da un quadro un po di
arte moderna si è scoperto una cosa
nuova che sistemano la come mai visto
questo effetto che colore dritto dritto
qualche colore più magari è proprio
bello vediamo il prossimo colore anno
bello mi piace mi piace allora colore
tutto questo mentre aspetti mischia
liste che casino che hai fatto qual è
stato
ok
vai se egli con prudenza non buttare la
mano così sennò ti capiterà il marrone o
per me le ha invece di era rosso di
arancione dai loro fan è bello dai sei
stato fortunato come diventerà la
bellissima bellissima idea è di vecchia
data che verrà il werder per questo sto
facendo tanto bisogno
e certo no è una sedia
allora se mi attira da questa parte c'è
qualcosa che mi attiro ma ho paura che
sia lì perde che mi sta tirando prendo
questo sei sicura ti do una possibilità
di cambiare ok non so se è una trappola
o no però cambia comunque prendo questo
perché
sì ma quando
quello con la colla bianca
[Musica]
ma scusa poi sai c'è una slide
trasparente il m colore bianco ma tanto
non lo colora avrebbe fatto tutti i
pallini bianchi
l'aiw trasparenti e adesso devo
ammettere il marrone si metta allora che
questo devo aprire di tale si stava
vendendo per me quel colore bendato
teche disastro di mezzo tantissimo
almeno così si vede un po di colore è
solo perché un bel colore rivestimenti
più stare sotto madre e figlia osso più
canzoni e adesso vediamo ancora più
bello il mio guardo cosa si sta
espandendosi piccolo extra
sapevo che possono ancora molto forte
quindi ma sembra tipo iii bernice così
come hanno l'olio queste tinte è molto
lucido sempre occorrenza di vedere come
diventeranno non è stato così anche
stupendo ok per dire che ci stupisce
anche questo era tra i pallini vedi non
è proprio stupore omogeneo un po di
pannelli nemica del loro show almeno che
effetto senti parchi nato spero che poi
ti capiterà il blue bird è dura allora
eccomi qua con il mio marrone
orribile vediamo questo piano perché
porta eppure scuro oddio è davvero non
ti dicono per sembra che la neo perché
vediamo un po come si colora i
cosiddetti letti davvero un quadro di
arte moderna e di uno che sta sentito
male di un pittore subito speriamo che
vi capiti un bel colore acceso per una
roba è spumeggiante ma che diventa scuro
questa è la tua ultima scelta è quindi
potresti migliorare lo slime penserà
roberts sempre un po arriva comunque
quello di giorgio 5 di colore sarebbe
diventato un bel mix ma se volete
portare ne facciamo cinque magari di se
stesse volte facciamo cinque allora
bene voluto carrozza esatti no questa
attenzione perché queste non scelte
importantissimo adulta è quella
definitiva sto sentendo come quello che
vediamo è ok
non lo so non giochiamo a nessuno ti
signore anche button e si chiama o le
voci nel cervello anche negozi ti dicono
che questa è per questo sono sempre più
allargata possa scegliere magari fai
così promuovere la luna è provveduti
nalles colore è questo secondo secondo
me è il resto è si vedono smette secondo
me questo aiuto perché sono rimasto così
ma vuoi scegliere questo o no io ho
sentito che hai fatto un mezzo diretto o
non fatto niente ma voglio voglio bene
davvero l'altro che che colorerà dato la
carica che colorerà era verde scopra
parlava lasciato questo mi sento
definitivo
[Musica]
cosa prime sei sempre il solito
fortunato fortuna pescara io devo per
forza prendere un colore bello acceso
altrimenti certo a fare il mio sly anche
marrone è acceso noti può riprendere un
rock sound caldo un arancione salvare
libro tutto grigio beige e gli volevo è
ho un sentore per questo colore qualcosa
mi dice di prenderlo e l'altro qualcosa
che ti viso che forse un errore e
prenderla dove cambiare avevo mai tenere
la scandinava ci hanno mandato magico
dico scarti e allora scarto però taglio
aiutato e sono stato bravo
stasera era stata comunque era un
marrone era un giallo fra sarebbe stato
male bello marrone
questo mi attira sei sicura che ti
attira la devi sentirla non so perché
ora che partita
non lo so mi stanno bene allora non ti
dico niente io cioè quello quello che
vuoi
nel senso che non ti dico niente
no ormai uno hai scartato vendite di
temere questo per forza a si va bene
allora tengo questa mamma mia ho sempre
di così triste magari un bel colore
viola che conterà un altro crisi sei
sicura era il rosa ma che vuoi
per fare bella figura 2 dottor dello
stato è perché dalla sua voce sembravano
non lo prese perché quello è bene ma non
ci son contenta con il viola pre
preferito ruota ma vabbè viola vediamo
se ricorda di qualche colore per cento
mai è il mio sarà il più bello chi
vincerà
indovina chi vincerà indovina ma questo
ancora più brillantissimo e brillante
guarda guarda e proprio come me
brillante bellissimo e colore punti
della specie di filetti bellissimo
bellissimo non vedo l'ora di vederlo
motivo proprio curioso di vedere come
diventa mamma mia quindi tesa disfatta
delle 36 sonosciuto il soddisfatto
l'attenzione si vedono ancora i puntini
grid del grigio che abbiamo messo
immagina allora se mettessimo ancora più
colori si sarebbero tanti punti secondo
me il tuo col viola lascerà molto molto
bello come coutinho mai un mio resterà
sempre più bello questo rosso rosso
fuoco ha chiuso ancora il ladro stai
mettendo e proveremo a farlo un po
decentemente mare proprio a vincere
contro pulito pellissimo rocco vediamo
come diventa non ne sono sicura
lidia un po acqua i filetti forse lo sta
colorando un pochino di più coloro in
particolare dai un po i viola comunque
per fortuna il viola poi i media il suo
no non è vero
secondo me questa è una volta attivato
diventa super bello piace più il viola
del rosso e avrebbero assunto un colore
decente invece di marrone quindi siamo
viola contro rosso chi inizierà ok
ragazzi ora andiamo ad attiva il nostro
troppo curioso di vedere come diventa e
poi potrete votare se ha vinto io ti di
giallo o se ha vinto generale si assiste
frasi 32
guardate un po come un sito io sono
veramente contento perché allora in un
sì tutto
non badate al tavolo sporco perché il
pratico phone e lo stiamo attivando ha
perso un po di colore infatti se volete
farlo anche voi con le tinte ad olio
state attenti se avete il tavolo bianco
comunque non fatelo sul tavolo è strano
perché le mani comunque non le
ammucchiate facciamo qualche residuo di
style però non mi ha macchiato le mani
ma la marchesa tavolo procuriamo però
non ha subito farmi vedere lo sai perché
è lucidissimo quarta volta in lucido a
parte il colore bellissimo non mi
aspettavo che uscisse così avrei
preferito se più chiaro però è uscito
una sorta di viola scuro viola prugna
la cosa che mi ha sorpreso è che è
lucidissimo
perché c'è l'olio in questo tinte e
nonostante non siano ancora andate via
le bolle della con la trasparenza
guardate un po che bello sarà di
liquirizia e trovano conte lucido
quindi ho scoperto che fare lo stanco la
tinta tolio non rendere lucidissimo però
state attenti appunto a non macchiarsi a
non macchiare dove quando fatto
l'estrema non macchiare il tavolo o la
superficie in estate con questo è stato
il contenta perché davvero belli che se
non super lucido e ora vediamo cosa di
vitali come diventare una caramella
quelli librizzi nozze americano che il
colore è bellissimo perché non proprio
rossa una sorta di arancione s perché
c'è il rosso quello forte forte quella
canzone che mi era capitato come secondo
colore è super lussino anche questo
pochi di spettacolare il colore
bellissimo davvero dove lo stupendo
abbiamo macchiato leggermente le mani
poco poco e non tanto però utenti
infatti come dice vanità prima serie
utilizzate su superficie bianca poi
lavate di subito le mani anche bello
bello davvero
allora che ha vinto secondo voi
mettiamoli uno a fianco all'altro nel
pozzetto rossa ecco il mio che lo
chiamerò mirtilli magie di mirtilli il
tuo come lo chiami per forza una
liquirizia e poi portava liquirizia
rossa vediamo prova il mio lucidissima
che tengo a un nuovo fido prodotti che
non è bello se non è bello anche il
colore hai visto che consigliato proprio
bene sui meriti di anche bene a mente un
colore più bello bello
ai ragazzi di vascotto basta votate ti
ho vinto io non li troviamo ed evitare
di un giorno potete di aver scoperto
questa nuova tecnica con lei con i
colori a un voleva molto molto belli non
aveva quasi l'uccide glossy bellissimi
per fare per se voi lo avete mai provato
e consigliateci nei porti per challenge
da fare assieme quando ad atelier e
tutto dica se volete
e il matrimonio originale pretendere le
altre challenge cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione